i think you could build a easily a
hundred thousand plus person
list doing this product and then there
is a clear like premium offering on the
back end
but the the core of it is quiz funnel up
top daily newsletter
and get there and get to a hundred
thousand i i would i'm on a throw down
the gauntlet for somebody who's
bored and looking for a project that
will actually stick they'll actually get
have some legs
uh because i know this will have legs
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what
all right everyone uh we're gonna talk
about some good stuff in this episode
but before you get to it can you do me a
favor
uh go to spotify and click the follow
button the reason why
is lately we've been getting way more
listeners on spotify and i think it's
because we're going up the charts but i
want to be sure of that
and in order to go up the charts i need
you to click follow so it's gonna be
like a big experiment
i'm gonna reveal the results next time
but go to spotify go to my first million
and click that blue button that says
follow click it for me
please i'll reveal the results soon i
think that's means we're gonna go up in
the chart all right first segment we're
gonna talk about horoscopes specifically
there's a couple of companies that we
talk about horoscopes.com astrology.com
sanctuaryworld.com that make literally
tens of millions of dollars a year
talking about
the horoscope business it's pretty wild
because something like 50
of uh women in america are interested in
that topic which i have no idea
we also talk about judge judy and
michael buffer i know that sounds weird
you may not even know that name michael
buffer his guy says let's get ready to
rumble we talk about those two folks and
how they make
something like 400 million dollars i
mean actually break down why
they make that money and how you can
replicate that and then finally we talk
about two little
side stories uh about side projects that
shawn and i have we actually launched
like
dozens of products that we've never even
these are our
embarrassing side projects that we
haven't talked about before that we uh
reveal
while we're talking about the horoscope
thing they range from starting a crystal
business
which is just weird even saying that and
they also to a a
fan page that i made for pitbulls it's
kind of odd and then finally i talk
about a story about meeting tim ferriss
and it actually happened when i was kind
of high on drugs one time you'll
you'll hear about it uh get to it uh
it's in the episode like us on spotify
see you at the end of the episode all
right what's going on we were just
talking about losing weight sean yeah
you look good um
how long have you been doing meat only
meat only is only four days in
but uh i had heard about this joe rogan
talked about the carnivore diet
and then uh it sounded [__]
ridiculous at the time
then you started sending me you know
nude selfies and you were like
i was like damn sam's pretty stacked
you're like yeah dude i'm just only
eating meat
i'm like what yeah yeah i'm only eating
meat i was like the second person
mentioned it and then my trainer was
like he's like getting shredded for kind
of his season or whatever
and he's like i was like so what
adjustments do you make he goes i just
go to kind of a
pretty much a meat-only diet protein
only grass-fed ground beef
uh grass-fed grass-fed beef some fish
that's pretty much it a little bit of
turkey and um
so i was like well i don't know if this
is gonna kill me later
but i'll do it for two months so let's
see if i
if there's any noticeable change so
we'll see well yeah
i was just saying you look great you
look uh you lost how many i mean i don't
know like pounds isn't the best way to
measure it but you probably have lost
the equivalent of like 30 pounds of fat
maybe 20 pounds of fat
uh i don't know that'd be a lot my
weight is the same or higher than it was
when i started working out but my
uh i do the dexa scan which we talked
about which is that business where you
go you lay down and it's like
it just shows you kind of like where the
fat muscle and bone is in your body sort
of like an mr
i don't know it looks like an mri
machine but it's not an mri
and uh according to that thing i've lost
you know like i don't forget like i do
it every three months and so the last
three months
i went down three or four percent body
fat now i'm going down another
four or five percent body fat this time
so yeah hopefully we'll lose like 10
of my body fat so the first idea i want
to discuss
is going to start with a fitness story
that's my segway but
before we get into that you're going to
do
and so for the listeners uh we're going
to do mini episodes i think you're going
to try the first one right
i don't remember what it's going to be
but you wanted to do a rant on something
and
we don't even need to say what it was
but we're gonna try a mini episode i
wonder if it's gonna work
it's gonna be probably five to ten
minutes long maybe we'll see yep
today we're gonna talk about um a
horoscope idea
which sounds silly but it's actually
gonna be pretty awesome then we're gonna
talk about judge judy michael buffer
which is actually gonna be pretty
awesome and then finally we're gonna
talk about something that i've asked
sean to prepare and it's about how he
manages this team of interns to get a
lot done
i want to get right into it so i want to
tell you the story about this guy named
ross clark
never heard you've never heard of ross
clark probably that's okay so he kind of
looks like me just a white hair blonde
corn fed looking dude from uh i believe
south carolina he was a triathlete
and he used to do soul cycle and he
would go to soul cycle
and he loved seeing these women walk out
of soul cycle with a glow
they had a they had a bunch of cot they
were very confident when they left and
he thought to himself
how do i make people feel like that i
want to make people feel confident i
want to make these
these women feel great about themselves
i want them to have a better life and so
he thinks what can i do
what can i do to make that happen and
then it hits him and it's kind of a
weird thing that hit him but he goes
the best way that i can do this is i
want to create a store
or a brand that sells crystals and
zodiac necklaces and t-shirts
and customized birth charts and geos and
smudge sticks these things that make
women feel great kind of weird right yes
and so that's what we're gonna talk
about the first idea uh and he
says he's gonna launch the like this
brand that creates all these
i consider them kind of weird kind of
woo-woo and he goes i'm going to create
a brand that sells all this stuff
but first i'm going to start with
horoscopes and that's the story of
sanctuaryworld.co so i guess it's i
think they just call it sanctuary
the url of sanctuary world dot co and
the reason we're gonna talk about it is
they just raised a seed round
of five million dollars is that correct
yeah something like that
so they raised five million dollars and
it's caused
a little bit of controversy because
horoscopes
are well they're [__]
they're [__] in the sense that
there's not a lot of facts behind them
they're not real um but a lot of people
buy into them
thinking that they are legitimate in
fact something like
40 of women check their horoscope on a
regular basis
and they they will make decisions based
off their horoscope and the reason why i
want to bring it up is because
a it's interesting so um by the way
what is this link to the soul cycle
thing that sounds like who's this guy
ross
ross parker is that his name that's the
story bro sounds like [__] to me
ross parker it sounds like
he was like oh women believe this [__]
people men believe this [__]
i'm gonna sell this [__] to them not i
was standing outside a soul cycle i saw
them glowing and happy
and somehow i connected the dots between
feeling good after
exercise to selling crystals and
horoscopes
that doesn't make any sense to me it's
it's a [__] story but
you told me what he's doing he's totally
well i'll give you that
he's connecting soul cycle he also in
the article that i read he
mentions headspace he's just name
dropping
right this is good he's trying to
associate
at one point he called it the uber for
zodiac signs
so yeah basically he's saying
if i say three or four legitimate
company names
alongside mine i too will get the halo
effect
of being bucketed in with those guys all
right i'm like meditation
i'm like religion i'm like fitness
yeah so that's what he did uh i mean
calm calm.com calls themselves the nike
of spiritual fitness so
hey look we're like i i hate the game
right all right
i'm not gonna hate the player um so let
me explain to you why
this is uh interesting so josh wolf a
guy that uh
i like you like he tweeted this is
[__] whoever
funds this idea is a crook um
and i actually don't entirely agree with
him i understand where he's coming from
though
and now i want to give you some
background about this app the industry
and where the opportunities are so
the way this app works is when i read
his tweet he goes
this is this is josh wolfe on twitter
he's a well-known vc he says
seriously shame on anyone for funding or
encouraging this [__]
no doubt there is demand but this isn't
peddling entertainment
it's encouraging slippery slope snake
oil flap doodle
we ought to desire informed educated
rational and not naive
gullible superstitious society and then
he screenshotted
all the investors who participated in
the round
i'm here for that shots fired although i
disagree with what he said go on
yes and so the way this app works i
downloaded it it's actually beautifully
designed and it sucked me in hardcore
and you sign up you see like a sp
dude i see the glow so i should have
known
it got me and you sign up you say what
you know
you click your jeff i'm a gemini i don't
know what the other 12 signs are but you
select your birthday and it says
today is your daily reading for your
horoscope uh it tells you
like it's i got these like text
messaging vibes so it feels like it's
texting me
this one or two sentence description of
what i should expect and then it says by
the way
we want to tell you more in a few hours
can you please turn notifications on so
we can tell you more in a few hours
about what's going to happen to you and
they use this language that speaks
exactly to me
and then they say also we have a little
bit more that we can tell you if you
sign up here
and then the way the app works is you
can have this premium subscription where
you get more info about you
or you can stay for free where you get
daily updates or now this is where it
gets interesting
you could pay a little bit more money
and you could talk to a live
what do they call themselves a mystic
yeah a reader
um you could talk to a reader and she'll
tell you all about you so so basically
we've talked about miss cleo and how she
made like a billion dollars
you get to talk to a miss cleo on the
phone or via text
and they're going to tell you all about
what you can expect for the coming year
the coming day
yada yada yada now that in itself is not
entirely interesting i mean it is pretty
interesting
but what's what's really interesting is
how big this is so as
two 30 something year old men we
probably don't know too much about this
but it's
way bigger than i ever thought and the
reason why i
started diving deep into this is i
started reading articles about the
horoscope industry in a lot of like
typical uh liberal high educated blogs
that were written by women and i would
have thought oh these women are gonna
[__] on it they're gonna say this is a
scam and you know what all the articles
were very positive right
even in tech crunch it was this woman
named sarah perez wrote about it and she
goes
yeah horoscopes aren't really harmful
it's just fun meaningless entertainment
whereas this guy josh completely [__] on
it and the reason why these women
perhaps were okay with it is something
like
50 percent of women check the horoscope
on a on a monthly basis 37
said they check daily um i always get
into these awkward situations my
sister-in-law
uh is a big believer in like the zodiac
thing so you know a situation will be
happening between her kids or
we'll be talking and she's like oh such
a tourist you know you're such a tourist
or like well that's because well that's
because uh you know they're gemini and
gemini are this way
and i'm always like you know i don't
know how to respond to this because i'm
like
yeah yeah but like that's totally fake
but yeah yeah that's super fake and true
yeah
okay good go on like i don't know what
to say in response to that like
i can't validate it or agree because i
don't agree
cuz who cares i don't i don't care if
she believes uh it puts me
i always say to them i say look if i was
if i came on
one second later at 1201 you're telling
me
that i'm gonna react differently about
this or that just because of that one
nanosecond
or i always say well what if i'm born in
australia where the hemisphere is
different and the seasons are different
and the moon's different
but it's the same by the way in india
they have this they have in india's like
this
times ten so if you think miss cleo was
big and miss cleo was big miss cleo i
think generated over a billion dollars
in sales if you're if you watch tv in
the 90s you know who miss cleo is if you
don't you know
um but uh in india they have this uh
still on tv
all the time there's these gurus these
mystics and in every village
even like the poorest villages in fact
especially in the poorest villages
because i think
that's where superstition and religion
is is stronger than anywhere else
um you take your when your kid is born
you take your kid to a uh
kind of like your local stargazer mystic
guy
and he's basically he writes this giant
thing on an act like on a scroll
he gives you a scroll and the scroll
basically says um
don't let him eat yellow lentils uh it's
just like all this like
hyper like he shall not be married in
the months of may
june or august and so people literally i
know that are like
you know educated doctors lawyers
bankers they'll be like engaged oh my
god when's the wedding this summer
they're like nah we
can't do summer i was like why because
my parents had this reading done when i
was
two months old and it told them that i
shall not be married in these months of
the year
and so this is not just like an american
thing it's a worldwide thing
under many many different names um this
is this is worldwide superstitions
it's wild and well i'm going to tell you
a little bit about the industry and some
other people succeeding in the space but
i think i couldn't find too much on
these folks revenue numbers because
they're
they're relatively new so the way that
the the company started was this young
guy or he's
i mean he's 39 he's ross clark or
whoever i said his name was he
he he was he went through lauren
michaels the guy who started or runs snl
he went through apparently he has a like
a digital incubator i guess the nbc or
someone sponsors
it's weird it's weird and he went
through it and now he recently raised
five million dollars including i guess
he raised money from nbc and lorne
michaels
somehow has a stake he raised money from
advanced capital
which advanced owns um loads and loads
of magazines
he raised money from uh graycroft which
is a media investor so he's raised money
from all these media people so this is
like a traditional
media company and or uh uh
traditional media people like this type
of stuff and the reason why they like
this is horoscope business has been a
large business for years and years and
years i mean i've already
just told you the numbers this is not
niche i mean we're talking like a third
of americans are into this [__]
um so astrology.com have you heard of
astrology.com
of course so they do low eight figures
in revenue
and the way that they make money is they
have they do a lot of programmatic
advertising so they do
low-cost advertising like environment
boolean operating they get you to come
to their website and make a little bit
of money off advertising
uh they have ads on their website so
it's an ad arbitrage play and then they
also sell subscriptions so
you do like a click this button and
you're gonna get a little bit of an
extra reading
they make uh tens of millions load tens
of millions doing that and it's been
like that for like 30 years
astrology.com horoscope.com
horoscope.com is another competitor they
do about 20
or they get about 20 million people
coming to their website a month so it's
quite large
these guys have been around since like
1995 1999.
so they've been around forever just
making 10 million plus in revenue
and kind of a pretty fascinating
business my opinion
about 15 million visitors a month to
their website
which is a lot that's a lot and i bet
you a lot of that is direct or search
which is really good
um yeah so which way do you want to go
with this so i
i think we can do a couple things one is
uh
there's the controversy you know vinod
khosla josh wolf they came out saying
oh how how evil for funding this and for
doing this there's
so there's agree or disagree there well
we could actually address that
right away which is they're i totally
disagree and they're [__] they're
wrong like let's like say like why would
you ever invest in a nicotine business
or an alcohol business like
dude there's there's a place for all
types of [__] or a burger chain
or netflix or whatever right like you
can
you can believe that uh there are
sort of negative consequences for
society and humanity for facebook
as well right i think in this case their
their sort of view
is very tainted and here's the here's
the easy example
if somebody was doing a religion app
they would be
they would never say anything about this
but because the religion is the stars
instead of the gods
um now it's snake oil now it's [__]
now it's you know peddling uh
you know fake science what is religion
what is the difference of religion right
like
it is a belief in something that is
supernatural
that is invisible that cannot be proved
by science it is blind faith
in something and that faith gives people
comfort entertainment
community you know like many like
positive benefits
and so if you're gonna say this about uh
horoscopes
you better also say it about religion
otherwise i i view you sort of as a
hypocrite
there yeah we're on the same page there
and also like dude i
like many people they have a shitty live
they go to work they get home at
5 p.m and they just want to [__] veg
out if if a little horoscope gives them
a little bit of hope
who cares uh you know we i need all the
help i can get and i'm sure a lot of
people do too
so i don't care so i will i i'll say
it's [__]
just like i think a lot of religion is
sorry if you're religious but i respect
that if you like it but i think it's
[__] too
but it's okay me too um okay so then the
second piece is
uh that i'll just say on that is [__]
annoying
the virtue signaling by vcs nobody
like this the grandstanding that people
do is so
annoying to me and i recently we'll talk
about this more
in a month uh a weird teaser i know but
we'll we'll go
i'm gonna go in depth about a topic in a
month about a fight i had on twitter
uh a good old twitter ruckus and but one
of the things that came out of it was
the just absolute hypocritical uh nature
of people
and and virtue signaling this is almost
more annoying to me than
uh like cancer culture is virtu virtue
signaling culture where
uh people take any chance they get to
say how they're greater than
others uh because you know they sort of
just go try to take the moral high
ground at any cost
and uh i find it to be so annoying and
such a like weak move of people to do
that so
if you're an investor to go and say i'm
a good guy i would never fund something
like this
um that is such an annoying move to me
uh personally what do you think of that
so
i completely agree with you i mean like
i think that we have to remember that
like
there's some mom like my mother in
missouri who's having a hard day
she needs to get off somehow like that
sounded weird but you know what i mean
she needs to like find her a little bit
of happiness somewhere i don't care if
she wants a soap opera or
reads about horoscopes who cares not
everything needs to save the world it
just needs to be a little bit of fun and
entertainment and
not everyone needs to agree with you
okay you don't want to fund it no
problem you don't have to fund it
but to like call out and demonize the
people that do fund it
let them do what they want uh like i
find it weird that the people who are
uh trying to be so like righteous
they lose the one like kind of like one
of the more fundamental things which is
open-mindedness
uh that maybe other people have
different beliefs than you and will act
in different ways in accordance of their
beliefs
and uh and that they should not be
judged or demonized for it so anyways i
think that's kind of annoying
but okay so for all the people who like
this
let's talk about the opportunities and
why this works you want to talk about
that yes
i have a couple okay i'll go first
the first is myers-briggs and other
personality tests you can do this exact
same thing with that by the way the
reason i bring this as
the most interesting subject to anybody
is themselves themselves exactly
and so that's the that's the umbrella
we're not talking about
selling pseudoscience yeah that's
actually like a technique
why does this work is because the most
interesting topic to me
is me and the most interesting topic to
you is you and so
because of that if you if you accept
that that is true which by the way it is
once you understand that that is true it
opens up a set of business possibilities
that you can go through and work through
and try to figure out uh so okay go on
so the goal is to find so the reason why
i went to this app why it was so
interesting i bet so for most apps the
free to paid conversion ratio
is probably one percent maybe you think
that's about right you can get higher
you can get to like three four percent
okay with this app i bet you it's as
high as ten percent if you
if they told me ten i wouldn't be
surprised i'd be impressed i'm not
surprised
i would be impressed and not surprised
exactly and at ten percent
uh free to paid conversion rate is
stupid that is so good
the reason why is good is you could
spend a lot of money to advertise now
the churn might be high but that's a
situation we could address after we're
already big and popular there but so the
reason why they're
they're let's just assume that that is
true let's say it's six percent
um the reason why it's six percent is
that it's so personal
and the we the reason this business
works is that it is personal so what you
need to do is go out and find
personal stuff so that's the reason why
myers any type of personality test
because i could say
oh so you've just told me these 10
things about you that means that you're
probably disorganized
right let me tell you all about being
disorganized and what that means
personality tests are great it's
actually the same in a way the same
thing as a horoscope
and what you can do is you could do it
you could really just do a daily email
if you wanted to
sound really simple by the way all those
people who are like um
horoscopes huh like yeah that's for dumb
trump voters to believe in
and then they'll also be putting on
their twitter bio like i'm an entj
right they'll go put their like [__]
personality quiz results
into their bio and i know there's
slightly more science that you know that
that says that that's a real thing
but uh i don't know this is all yeah
exactly
this is all hand wavy [__] as far as i'm
concerned yeah and
and guess what i'm in favor of it all
right um i take these tests oh i enjoy
them
so i think that you can do a daily email
for this um
i also think that paid content paid
subscriptions for these types of things
works really well and what this app is
doing
that i particularly love that i think
could work for so many different things
is you get a top of funnel thing where
you give these tests and then you do a
come and talk to a person and you will
charge 50
per person or per hour or whatever it is
and as a middle person you take a cut i
think that is brilliant
by the way i was talking to um there was
a company we talked about on here
it's called i feel like it's called
intro was it called intro it was
basically like
you can book a call with like justin
bieber's stylist
or like um oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was called intro camera call
no it was called something else but you
oh maybe you're right so
anyways dot com right uh founder's legit
sold his last company he starts this
thing he's like oh it's great because
i'm remodeling
my kitchen wouldn't it be great to be
able to do a 30 minute call with
the person who remodels kitchens on httv
and so they got all these stars on and
it's all good guess what vertical is the
number one vertical for them
astrology readings they found all these
instagrammers
you can go on instagram you could find
all these people who have like cult
instagram followings they have like
50 000 150 000 followers and they just
post a daily sort of like
you know reading and the people will pay
to book time to get a personal reading
from them
it's taking off now he doesn't publicize
that if you go to the website it still
looks like it's about
style home renovations and everything
yeah and that isn't fitness
but nutrition makeup fitness nutrition
makeup all these things that
you know smart people will nod their
head and say that sounds good that
sounds healthy
uh then it's like what do people really
want where's the where's the highest
demand it was in the
tell me about me through a reading
either a psychic reading astrology
reading whatever it is
um okay i want to go back to something
you said very quickly
but i think is super legit and this is
we need a sound effect for whenever
me and you have such total conviction
it's like in um
if you watch like uh i don't know
america's got talent or something like
that or or the extra buzzer the golden
button the golden buzzer where they're
just like
we don't need to vote i'm gonna push
this button right now and you're you
automatically advance
so i'm pushing the golden button right
now for anybody who wants to take this
idea
of um creating this this funnel
so to do this you need you need to know
nothing about code but you do need to be
kind of like
internet savvy and kind of clever here's
what you do you and you should probably
go and read
like ryan hoover's book hooked near iowa
or
yeah ryan who was like the editor
whatever sorry
near or go and read um influence by
robert
exactly somebody who who gets into this
stuff and is nonjudgmental
they're not gonna do this forever but
here's the experiment the experiment is
you create a quiz that's the top of the
funnel that basically says
find out your personality find out your
ex find out your myers-briggs find out
whatever it is
your horoscope whatever and uh you
create a quiz at the top
and then to get your results you put in
your email we email you the results
and then we send you a daily newsletter
that's personalized to you
right because you are a um because you
were born on this day
of this year i'm gonna give you your
daily horoscope i'm gonna give you your
daily reading and
so that's the whole product right now uh
i think if we do this
i i will put put money in i bet sam
would put money in too you put a little
money behind the paid
acquisition here and um and there's
inherent virality because people will
share their
their quiz results they will share their
readings especially when it says like
see if you're compatible with your
brother your girlfriend your mother
whoever right
you'll get somebody to share the quiz
with somebody else so i think you could
build a
easily 100 000 plus person list doing
this product
and then there is a clear like premium
offering on the back end
but the the core of it is quiz funnel up
top daily newsletter
and get there and get to a hundred
thousand i i would i'm on a throw down
the gauntlet for somebody who's
bored and looking for a project that
will actually stick they'll actually get
have some legs
because i know this would have legs and
i don't know how big a legs or
but i do i would say with a high degree
of certainty
if you work on this full time for three
years you have a five million dollar a
year in revenue
or even simpler right like a lot of
people who who i when i surveyed my
audience one of the biggest things was
dude i'd love to just have a side hustle
that i could do a few hours a day
that would bring in a few thousand
dollars a month
this will do that so if you want to do
this dm me
email me email email us find out find a
way to contact us
because i want somebody legit to
actually try this let me tell you uh
about some experiments i've done in this
area i don't even know if you know about
these things so
i don't know when it was not too long
ago within the last couple years
i was quite bored um i had sold my
company and i basically said
you know last episode you asked like do
you want to build something that lasts
for like 30 40 years
like like a long-lasting company i'm
like yeah sometimes i dream about that
and then sometimes i dream about
what's something i could do this weekend
that would be fun and like
i could throw away next weekend if i
wanted to like a low commitment fling of
a business just a fun scheme right
a hookup and so i wanted i wanted a
business hookup
and yeah one night stand and i created
thr i created three ideas that i thought
would work
the first was a iq test i always wanted
to know my iq
i don't know my iq i'd like to think i'm
smart i think i'm above average smart
guess what everybody thinks they're
above average smart and so
i thought why isn't there like an easier
way to do an iq test why
if there was an ad on facebook that was
like a puzzle
and it's like solve this puzzle and this
is like the start of an iq test
um i would go through that i would take
the iq test for 20 minutes and then i
would want to get my results i'd give
you my email
and i might even pay for like the full
results of this thing
so i thought that was kind of
interesting doing iq tests and kind of
like recreating
mensa uh as a sort of like online funnel
again no physical product needed no
shipping no logistics no supply chain
but a pure play sort of digital info
product
second one have you read the book the uh
five love languages or
five languages of love obviously
okay yeah you're married so at some
point you were given this book i've been
like
hey [__] uh read this
yes and so that's one that that's a
pretty successful franchise
so if you go look at my facebook page
right now my facebook profile
you'll see oh why is shawn the admin of
a page called the love doctor
well let me tell you why because i
wanted to take the five love languages
test
put it online send people through that
flow where they answer a bunch of
questions and then say would you like to
know what your love language is
get put your email in and then i'll send
you your results and then i say
well wait we need to see who you're
compatible with do your love languages
match and do they know yours
send this to your partner and um boom
and then
by the way like here buy the ebook buy
the pdf
that will tell you what to do given your
love language because there's only like
five
so i can just make five pdfs and sell
them so these are these little business
experiment links and i have one last one
that i did
because as you can tell these types of
businesses appeal to me
i like simple lightweight stuff that
people uh that has a lot of demand that
silicon valley likes to pooh-pooh and
say that they're they're better than
that
uh i find this as an opportunity so the
last one is crystals
uh you said something oh my gosh yes i
did so this guy what he wants to do is
he wants to sell
crystals i don't like i i don't and i
don't say oh my gosh and like i think
it's wrong to say
sell because um i think it's like
anything that
like you know tony robbins is he
[__] yeah but
i read it sometimes it makes you feel
like helpful so
so who cares but i think crystals are
nonsense yes
exactly so so is a placebo a bad thing
right if this thing has no
measurable effects but i believe it to
have a positive effect and it helps me
feel better uh then has it not achieved
its purpose of helping me feel better
right
so um so i looked at these three ideas
and i had to pick one because i didn't
have too much time right i had a weekend
hookup to go to so i said
should i do the iq one should i do this
love doctor one the five languages love
test
or should i do this crystal thing as i
looked at the crystal thing i saw i saw
a bunch of interesting things which is
that
there's a lot of female kind of like
influencers
so adele carries a rose quartz crystal
with her
and uses it before ever before she goes
on stage for every performance uh
gwyneth paltrow from
you know with goop she's all about you
know these uh all about crystals
um you know just go through the list of
who's who so the kardashians
after kim kardashian got mugged or
robbed and she was feeling like very
unsafe
she uh like she credits crystals to
being one of the things that helped her
center herself calm herself and feel
better about herself and be able to go
back in the world feel safe again
so i found that wow a lot of these sort
of like female
celebrities and idols have pictures and
quotes with these i thought oh that'd be
pretty useful to help sell this thing
and then i found that i could
source crystals uh very easily right the
crystals are not that expensive
and so i created a uh e-commerce store
for crystals and i tried it for a couple
weekends
and i spent you know five ten grand of
booting this thing up
and i broke even and i even made a
little bit of profit and in the end i
sort of like got bored of the
you know i got bored of the hook up and
i was ready to move on with my yeah but
i kind of validated that this idea
could kind of work and there was it
wasn't like gangbusters like
look if they started printing money i
wouldn't have given it up um no but it
could have been
i mean you only did it for a few weeks
right like which is most things you have
to stay at it for a bit to actually get
it to work
that's brilliant i like hearing these
stories and i
as i was thinking i made fun of crystals
but
i actually had something similar so
there's this guy named ryan holiday you
know ryan holliday the author
of trust me i'm lying is that it yeah
i might have it yeah the enemy i think
is one of his right
i have some of them up here and he's got
many books and his famous thing is
stoicism so he talks a lot about
stoicism which basically just means how
to be uh how to deal with the adversity
how to be a tough guy
obviously horoscope's mostly women this
is probably mostly men
and i read one of one of his books i
thought it was nice it made me feel
better about myself
and i went to daleystoke.com and i
bought a 30
coin that says some greek thing on there
that's
i don't even know what it says but it
translates into like
you live and then you're gonna die so
like live well or something like that
it's just and i would carry it i always
like that dude who gets the uh the
tattoo of an asian
asian character on his arm and doesn't
know what it means yeah i
i don't but it doesn't matter like it
means something to you
yeah like it's uh got a like stoic on
there
they're supposed to be tough and i would
carry it around me and i paid 30 bucks
for it i think it costs a dollar for him
to make
i think make it a few million dollars so
that [__] works uh
i dig it and by the way my my one night
stand recently
uh about a couple years ago as well our
friend ramon was killing it on dog stuff
i'm like oh my gosh that that looks so
fun and so he would create all these
facebook pages
about uh dedicated to a specific dog
breed and i go well
that sucks fun i just want to tinker i'm
going to try it i created this one page
called bully boo
so the word bully and then space the
word boo b-o-o i just made that word up
bully is a like a bully breeds they're
like pit bulls
uh whatever yada yada and i just went
and got viral videos from reddit and i
posted it on bully boo
dude i got like 10 000 followers on
facebook like in a matter of like five
days
yeah so that [__] works um so anyway by
the way i also have a pet one i heard
this guy was making a bunch of money
when he
uh by printing your pet's photo on socks
as a gift and uh i was like great
weekend hookup tried it
spun up the whole thing uh had a guy my
friend eric who
has this cool sock company called tribe
he was like i'll print the socks for you
you here's a link here's what here's
here's an easy way to set it up
tried it uh my results weren't great but
uh same sort of thing where i was like
i really enjoy these mini experiments
and here's the thing like
when i share these i think part of it is
interesting of just hearing these little
like random things
most people listen to this i don't think
do that i think we're somewhat
unique in that we have done many of
these right like
i didn't even know you did this bully
boo thing you didn't know i've done
these three things there's actually like
10 more that i've done that you've done
that we
talked about so a lot of which are so
embarrassing
these are the ones we're talking about
imagine the ones we don't talk about so
um
so i think one of the like meta
takeaways is
um like just experiment more and be
willing to
spin something up quickly and then throw
it away when you when you're done with
it
and uh like don't try to like marry
every
everything you know it's okay to date
it's okay to have a hookup or a fling or
a one-night stand with a business
and um i think that it's a lot of where
skill is built
so in doing that um i used to tell kind
of one of one of my interns who was
working with me on the crystal thing he
was like dude i don't know if this
crystal thing's gonna work but i'm just
i'm amazed that in 48 hours
we went from you were just bullshitting
about the idea to
our first sale and that's just kind of
amazing he called it a flash brand
he's like i love that we just created
this whole brand it looks real it's got
a name
we like named it after my sister's kid
um you know like we
we we created a logo we got this like
this shopify store
spun up and in doing so we learned all
these like mechanics of like
how do you how like how do you get
better at writing copy how do you get
rid of naming things how do you get
better at making a logo
how do you use these tools like shopify
and clavio and all these different
tools that you need the piping to sell
to sell stuff
and i think that there's a lot of even
if you think the ideas we're talking
about are dumb
it's not dumb to like use these as an
excuse to go learn about facebook ads
or to learn about building a facebook
page quickly because that might come in
handy again
three days later or three years later
when you're trying to do the next thing
and of course that's not really what
you're the most important thing you're
learning what you're learning is the
confidence to just go through the motion
and get [__] done
in the same way that like it's a lot
easier to get skinny when you know how
to bench press properly or you feel
comfortable squatting and you're like oh
yeah i just do this this this and i eat
less and
boom i'm confident i can i just follow
the i guess can i tell you a mini story
on this real quick and then we'll move
on
um so i invested in that company maven
uh which is started by our mutual friend
uh guggen biani he started udemy and now
he's got it which is a three billion
dollar edtech company and now he's got a
new edtech company
uh for teaching online and i invested in
the company in order to get in it was
such a competitive deal in order to get
in he's like look
you guys have a good audience like um
you have a big twitter following
you gotta you gotta do a course if you
if you agree to do a course be one of
the teachers so be a user
then i'll let you in the round and i was
like done because i wanted to invest
and so then he's been hitting me up like
dude do the
where's your course come on man make
your course and so i was like all right
[__]
and so then i and i was overthinking it
and the lesson here is not it's really
has nothing to do with my course
um or i guess i'll tell the end of the
story and then i'll tell you what
how i almost [__] up so the end of the
story is yesterday i took
about 20 minutes i wrote a three tweet
tweet storm about
how writing has helped me and uh i said
you know in school i was a shitty writer
uh in school they want you to write long
essays like they have like a minimum
word count you have to hit literally
and you know you study shakespeare and
you think that's what good writing is or
you read the odyssey
um but then you know in the real world
it's the exact opposite
you know you're paid to be concise not
have a lot of words right
you're not trying to write like really
epic complex things you need to be
simple and crisp
and communicate well and i said i've
gotten good at that so i sucked at
school writing
but i've gotten pretty good at real
world writing through trial and error
and studying some of the best people
yourself included our friend neville i
bought his course
i took that whole thing i got better at
copywriting uh but i said in general
there's this whole like
like how much value can be unlocked if
you're good at writing emails
tweets blog posts company memos investor
uh
letters like all those things can
generate a lot of value it's made me
millions of dollars
uh i think it can do that for other
people too if you get better at writing
so anyways
i tweeted that out and i said i want a
package you know i've probably studied
this stuff for like a thousand hours in
my life
i want to distill it down into something
you can learn in 10 days if you're
interested in that it'll cost 400 bucks
um here's a link put it into a shitty
google form where you put in your name
and email
and you tell me why you want to take
this course so i've tweeted it out
um guess how many responses i got
300. so i got a thousand responses
already of people who are who gave me
all their info
that said i'd like to sign up to be in
the first batch i thought so the way
that maven works is they encourage you
to do this to test demand to see if you
have 100 people if you get 100 people
they say
all right there's enough demand you
should go like kind of figure out why
they want to do this and then
then launch your actual course a
thousand blew me away off of
you know one tweet basically um let
alone
email list or anything else so i thought
oh that's interesting wow like
let's say that let's let's say that this
is a thousand people the course cost
four hundred dollars
not all of them will convert but like
two hundred maybe
this uh but this was a hundred he said
about thirty to forty percent of people
will end up converting of but uh that's
if once you qualify the list a little
bit
so but even this was just one tweet so
let's assume i also email it out or i
tweet again about it
i think i could probably triple the size
of the interest list because
this was just whoever was on twitter in
that moment that saw it so i could
probably triple the size of this list
and then let's say 30 of them convert 25
of them convert okay so
let's say the net net is 120 000 i could
easily make six figures
i think 100 000 on the low end four
hundred thousand five hundred thousand
on the high end of this course okay so
that's
sweet but um what's the lesson here the
lesson here is actually that
i didn't i was not gonna send this tweet
uh i was telling
like governor's like all right you know
you need to like test your test of
demand for this course
and i was like great uh so here's my
plan i'm gonna first i'm gonna like
work on the content of the course i'm
gonna like make sure it's good
uh and then actually i wanna like show
people i'm good at this so i'm gonna do
like
10 examples i'm going to do 10 emails
showing me like taking something that
was kind of bad writing and turning it
making it better
so that'll like get people interested
and then i'll do it i'll mention it on
the podcast and then i'll do this other
thing and he's like
dude you don't need to do all that like
trust me just say hey i'm thinking about
doing this
uh you know here's why i think it would
be good for you if you're interested
sign up
and i was like yeah [__] you're right
i'm doing that thing and that thing
is what most people do which is you're
afraid to fail
so you overthink what you need to do to
make it successful
and abreu you're listening to this
you're about to go to your own startup
don't make this mistake that i was about
to make that i've made many times in the
past that
most people make every time they go do a
new venture is that they
are afraid to fail therefore they
um you know they they overestimate what
they need to do to get started
i need to incorporate i need to come up
with a good name i need to buy the
domain
i need to like build it to make sure i
you know i want to have a high quality
product i don't want to go out with a
bad product
and disappoint people uh or you know i
need to like
create a whole website before i do this
thing nope shitty tweet shitty google
form 1000 responses right like
you can get results with a much shittier
sort of go-to-market and so you know the
classic quote here is if you're not
embarrassed by your by your first
product
you you by your first version of your
product you waited too long to launch
and so anyways i relearned was
don't overthink it i i almost
overthought it do you know what you're
gonna teach
are you gonna figure that out uh yeah i
have a good idea actually i i think this
would be cool so
uh tell me what you think of this i
haven't told anybody this yet
so i think the way to get good at
writing is to write
obviously sorry it's the way to get good
at anything is to do it
um and so i'm like all right but i can't
just tell you to go do it if if it was
that easy you would have already done it
um so i thought okay what about this
what if
every day i gave you a prompt so like
let's say let's say the we want to get
better writing
uh writing for the real world right so
let's let's say it's a cold email
like the way you cold emailed people to
come be speakers at hustle con
great so i say we're gonna write a cold
email to somebody who you want to come
speak at your event
um i'm not gonna tell you how to do it
first try it take put 15 minutes on the
clock and just try it
write a shitty version um so they try it
then i'm going to give them a like a
kind of a
learning so it's like do learn and then
do so
then i tell you how i would do it and
with four examples like here's
here's one way of doing it there's
another way doing there's another way of
doing it here's the common principles
i'm using in all these
all right you learned that good now do
it again and you submit that one and
i'll give feedback on all the
submissions that people give and being
like hey this is actually awesome or
hey this is much better than your first
attempt look in 30 minutes you just went
from like really shitty
to pretty good and here's how you can go
from pretty good to like amazing if you
made this one tweak
additional so i want people to get uh
daily reps
at writing one of those things so it
might be a headline right here's the
story write the headline
okay cool that's a that was a bad
headline here's here's what goes into a
great headline you better launch it
again
you better launch fast someone a
listener is going to go and do this of
course they don't have 150 000 followers
but
yeah if you want to do this help me do
it i think it's just this should exist i
think this would be a cool way for
people to
get better by actually doing something
and doing it in like a controlled
sandbox
so not just saying open it i don't know
go write a bunch of [__] it's like very
specific
write this here's examples of what what
what good looks like and then
boom boom now that you know the now that
you've learned the principle go apply it
so anyways that's what i'm going to try
to teach do you want to talk about
michael buffer
yes what do you so on our doc
sean's got michael buffer and judge judy
personal monopoly written down there
i'm very curious what that even means so
this started with just curiosity i was
watching the um canelo alvarez
boxing match that happened last weekend
fun match guy when he
[__] broke this guy's face he's like
close together broke his book his face
in three places and then the guy
quit between rounds so anyways boxing is
this funny thing where like the match
itself
only lasts for you know some number of
minutes but they need to charge you
all this money for a pay-per-view so
there's all this like pomp and
circumstances all this parade around it
right
they walk out with music and their kind
of entourage and their outfit
and then the next person walks out and
then there's the introduction and in the
introduction there's
always this guy you've probably seen him
it's this white guy who basically is
like got a great voice
and in boxing he says um like you know
ladies and gentlemen
let's get ready to rumble right that's
like the signature thing uh like he you
kind of get wired
over the years of following the sport
that like yes this is the main event
this is the big one
and by the way do you know who that
guy's brother is bruce buffer right so
bruce is in the ufc and he says i'll let
you do it
he goes it's time
it's time and by the way they didn't
know that they were brothers until they
were like both in their 50s exactly
crazy story so so i so i i was just
watching this and i was like
how much does michael buffer get paid
right so i do the search
michael buffer salary guess do you know
how much
you might know it sounds like you know
some things no i i don't know but
10 million a year so michael buffer has
made 400 million dollars
uh in his career doing what he's doing
he's made
most of that off of the the fact that he
has created a personal monopoly he is
synonymous with a big boxing match
and his phrase let's get ready to rumble
is a trademarked phrase now how is it a
trademark and he's trademarked and he
licenses it out
to video games to um you know like
movies and shows and stuff like that
and actually if you go watch uh like the
back catalog of ufc fights
they cut out bruce buffer's it's time
part because they don't want to pan the
royalty
on its time how well first of all i knew
he was wealthy because he looks like
he's got a lot of work done on his face
so like
he's got that like wayne newton look
where like sigmund freud where i'm like
oh that's that las vegas rich look
and uh the second how on earth does the
boxing
federation or whatever it's called allow
him to own it along with bruce buffalo
so the
way this happens so the way it happened
was michael buffer
is the is the the announcer guy right
and at first he's not making much
and boxing is kind of nascent and he's
he grew with the sport right so
tyson got popular and holyfield and all
these big names
you know you just keep seeing this one
guy for like 30 years so he ended up
building
his own brand you know along the way so
nowadays he gets paid about
um or sorry i don't know exactly what
michael buffer gets paid per event
but he he got to the point where it's
let's say 1984
and he's saying let's get ready to
rumble and
uh bruce buffer uh who doesn't know that
they are
siblings he is half uh they're half
sibling so he's watching
um what is it he's watching the event or
something like that
and he sees that this guy's last name is
buffer and he goes
oh that's cool i've never met another
buffer he doesn't think they're brothers
he just thinks this guy's last name is
also buffer that's cool
i've never met another buffer he goes on
the yellow pages and he looks and
there's no other buffers
so he's like dude this is crazy this
guy's last name is buffer
and he's driving with his dad or
something like that and he asks his dad
he's like yeah this guy's uh oh no he
finds out he so he looks into michael
buffer he finds out
he was um he grew up in a town like i
don't know half a mile away from bruce
he's like dude dad how crazy is this
this guy you know that guy on the boxing
thing
michael buffer he last name buffer and
he grew up
uh you know half a mile half a mile away
from us and the dad while driving just
goes
yeah i think that's your brother he's
like what he's like yeah you know you
didn't know this but before you and your
mom you know they've been married for 50
years before you and your mom got
together uh you know
i had another i had a son i don't know
if it's him but maybe that's your
brother
and so they go and they find out that
they are actually half brothers they
share a dad
so bruce then goes to michael and he
says
michael you're doing great um but you
have no like
business manager i'll be your manager
and he's like okay what does that mean
he goes dude
you need to trademark this phrase this
is your catchphrase
so he applies for the trademark he gets
it and then he basically
says uh takes that trademark and he
starts licensing it out merchandise
you know hats shirts video games
everything so he starts building this
guy's brand
and then later michael gets bruce into
the comment the announcing game
and bruce becomes the announcer for the
ufc so a different sport
and bruce is making like on any given
event if you go watch a ufc event he's
making 50 to 100 grand for that night's
work
which is basically before every fight he
just announces you know in this corner
we have this guy
right now he makes hundred grand for big
fights and fifty grandish and this
you're like
we got a caveat this is like you know
when you google someone's net worth like
i don't know if this is actually his
number this is like the this is the it's
in a bunch of articles but maybe they're
all referencing the same shitty source i
don't know
right and he does probably three a month
yeah so you're looking at
about three and a half four million
dollars a year and it says that you know
his net worth net worth is sort of in
the tens of millions uh whereas michael
buffer is in the hundreds of millions
uh and so this sort of came to this
concept of creating a personal monopoly
so how do you build yourself to the
point where you are unreplaceable
um where and this is like um ryan
seacrest with american idol right
when american idol first started there's
two dudes and at this point ryan
seacrest
actually go ahead well i was just gonna
say ryan seacrest is now you know sort
of synonymous with
american idol uh it's like chris
harrison with the bachelor it's jeff
probst with survivor
and you know these are these are hosts
that on the surface it's like oh he just
comes out here says a few lines anybody
could do that no it doesn't take any
time no
no the fans grow attached to this person
and that becomes part of the brand of
the event
um and the consistency of seeing those
same faces the same recurring cast
members
saying the same catch phrases is part of
what makes it popular
so judge jude and at this point ryan
seacrest has
ryan seacrest productions which is a
production company which frankly
i've always been wondering like what
does a production company actually mean
like that that's one of those hollywood
terms that i'm sure it doesn't confuse
me i don't
get it but it does something like north
of 100 million in revenue well he
produced
the kardashians show keeping up with the
kardashians he was the creator and
producer of that show i think
so uh it was his idea so he parlayed
that into something i don't i don't
exactly like i said i don't entirely
understand that there's this company on
the road
because at the beginning of american
idol there was two hosts and one guy
after season one was like oh this is a
hit i want more money
and at that time he didn't have a
personal monopoly yet he was replaceable
because the show was so new
and so they said no thanks we'll keep
ryan ryan you could just be the lead guy
now
and ryan seacrest did it for like 15
years and then by the end of it was sort
of making i don't know 10 15
million bucks a season doing it because
he waited until he became
entrenched in the franchise as like the
face
and he became a valuable character like
simon cowell and the other guys
so judge judy is probably the greatest
example of this so the highest paid
person on tv
was judge judy for a number of years she
was making 47 million dollars
a year for i don't know 50 i think days
of filming so she was making about 900
a day uh filming the show for judge judy
which is she was a judge before that
making 113 000
a year and so from the commodity the
skill of the job of being a judge
to building your personal monopoly as
the show is called judge judy
she was able to turn 113 000 a year of
of
uh pricing power into 47 million dollars
a year and then
you know cbs bought the back catalog of
judge judy for 100 million dollars so
she's still making royalties without
working anymore
so i just find this to be tremendously
interesting it's something that was
counterintuitive to me
seems to me like all these people are
replaceable but clearly the economics of
hollywood show that they're not
and um and so i just found this to be
very interesting i also like the story
of you know the long lost brothers one
brother finds the other
becomes his manager convinces him to
trademark it and that trademark is
you know that building that personal
monopoly of ip is what helped him build
a multi hundred million dollar
franchise so i thought that was amazing
so i would let's go down the strap hole
i don't think we're gonna get to the
intern thing but maybe we will
um let's put on the shred hole because i
know a few people that have these
personal brands maybe some people think
that i have that but i
i actually don't have it because i'm not
nearly careful enough but you're you
seem quite careful enough
uh about your brand that you might uh
you you have this but who comes down
i know tim tim ferriss i know tim
ferriss i know
jack butcher jack butcher is a great
friend of mine um
he created this huge following off of
visualize value great name all he does
is he makes
one picture that describes a thousand
words so basically you have this
complicated topic
he makes one graphic a day and it
explains exactly how it works
you would think that's silly he's
crushed it he probably makes two to
three million dollars a year
uh selling a course on that topic the
second one tim ferriss
and the reason why i can't do this is
because these guys are so
protective and particular about their
brand tim ferriss i'm gonna tell
i'm gonna tell tim ferris story that i i
don't want to turn this into clips i
don't want this to get popular but i'm
going to tell a story
so tim ferriss years ago came to my
office when it was when he had justin
i i know tim ferriss because he would
walk his dog we were neighbors
we lived down the block from each other
we would walk our dogs together like he
would be at the park and i would be at
the park
and i wouldn't bring up business i
wouldn't even act like i was
a fan other than i'm saying hey i just
listened to this podcast the other day
was wonderful good job
uh anyway can you tell the first time
y'all met how did you because i think
when people meet somebody that they
know and admire they often blow it by
totally fangirling over them
uh what was the story do you even
remember like what was the first
interaction where it became
okay the funny story is i was on the way
home from the hospital after getting a
kidney stone and i was super high on
morphine i had gotten a kidney stone and
my wife sarah who was my girlfriend time
was driving me home
it was 8 am because i got the kidney
stone at like 5 o'clock in the morning i
was coming home eight a.m
i see tim walking in front of my house
and i was on the passenger seat riding
dirty with my seat
back and i was all high and [__] and i
see him walk by and i go
hold on sarah back up hey hey tim
what are you doing around here man and
he goes i live down the street i go
that's cool
i'm a big fan uh just got a kidney stone
he got any tips for that
and uh i was like oh obnoxious and then
i saw him again the next day walking his
dog and i go tim i just wanted to
apologize i was under the influence
but uh anyway i know your books uh big
fan um
what's what's your dog saying yeah
that's it right and then we would just
we would just talk about dogs that's all
and then eventually
he uh cold emailed me months later when
he goes hey i heard about the hustle
it seems cool do you want to have dinner
so we could talk about it i go to dinner
and he goes wait a minute you're the guy
with the dog i go yeah man what's going
on it's me sam i'm your neighbor
i didn't ever want to bring up email or
business to you because uh you know i
don't want to be tacky
so it was a weird thing that we knew
each other and so one day he after he
invested in my company he comes to the
office
he sees me drinking a coke cereal and he
goes hey man can i have one of those i
go
yeah dude you have as many as you want
let me go get you one i give him one
and he chugs it super fast he goes did i
get one more i go yeah i got two
i brought them two chugs we get done
with this meeting there's six of us in
the office
i'm in we're in a little baby conference
room which is basically a one bedroom
a bedroom in one of the apartments
there's about six of my employees or
four of them and then sieva was there
and he goes all right well that's a good
meeting and he pushes the coke cans my
way and i go what he goes you mind
throwing those away for me
and i go yeah yeah i'll come away and i
take him and he just didn't want to be
seen walking out with a diet soda can
that's how particular this guy was and
you know what
i think it's great i dig it and whenever
we work with tim
um if i write something and there's a
miss comma or something he's on top
right and at first i was like you know
you're really being a pain in the butt
and then i realized you know what you're
not being a pain in the butt you are
being tempted
you are being exactly how you should be
you are protecting your brand
you want things in a very particular way
you're being demanding and i respect
that and i like that and that's when i
realized
i don't think i could ever be a personal
brand because you have to guard that
[__] like crazy
you have to be on top of it every single
time it has to be
uh it's got to be exactly a very
particular way every single time and
that's how you build a really good brand
um you have to be on when you're on i
mean i'm sure there's a phrase i use i
i don't know if i made this up or
somebody told me this i have no idea it
was a long time ago 10 years ago
it's called epoch epoc it stands for
every point of
contact it said if you want to make a
great brand you need to be congruent so
you need to have
something you stand for all right most
people don't know what they stand for
they're not clear about it
it's not unique it's not compelling it's
not um it's not something notable
but once you do that the second step is
at every point of contact you have to
embody that right so
you can't be before our body and be out
of shape
right you can't be like you know for our
work week guy
and then you know you're super
inefficient and you're working 80 hours
a week
so so you have to be congruent at all
times
and that's that should be the goal as a
brand is to at every point of contact a
customer has with you
in any any place they're getting that
same
they're getting that same thing that you
stand for and um and so that's that's
like an aspirational goal of course you
don't do that it's not
it's not achievable but it is a mindset
to have in order to reinforce the brand
many many times
because people will have experiences
with you right this is like disney world
disney world has all these things right
where they're like you know there's no
um i forgot what all the things are it's
like there's no trash cans and there's
no like
uh you can't see the mascots ever taking
a smoke break with their head off you
know you can't see mickey mouse smoking
a cigarette
it's like no we have to be at every
point of contact
this place stands for joy then
everything's got to be joy right the
bathroom's got to be joy the food's got
to be joy right like all these different
things
um that's what great sort of brand
owners are
or strive to do and what you and i do or
at least i know i do it is
um i test stuff with people and so in a
way we have a podcast
i mean i would say we're actually what
you see is what you get i mean we i you
and i talk like this regardless if
the camera's on or not but um i do know
like which jokes hit
and i'll test them on people right i
kind of see like oh this story i just
told
it caught that guy's attention i should
tell it a little bit differently though
and with tim and other people i've seen
them repeat
phrases like um uh i don't pretend to be
a doctor and i don't play one on tv
right like that's just like this phrase
that he uses and i guess
it kind of and yeah you're so likely
yeah yeah
and and and these phrases that i've seen
these quote famous people so a guy like
tim who else do i know that's like fits
this category jack is definitely one of
them
um jack butcher um i've told the story
before
on the pod but chris saka did this and
it blew me away i met him in person
and for those who don't know chris hawk
is like one of the best investors ever
to a point where he's already retired he
doesn't
now he only invests in climate change
stuff because he's like already i
already won the game of like money and
success
he's it's called post-economic yeah he's
post-economic as biology taught us uh
so i met him in person and he told this
story
and as i was telling the story he had
all these little offhand
little moments where he's like he's like
you know i didn't i didn't realize that
that at the time um or like he'd be like
he'd say something he'd correct himself
and he'd be like blah blah
well i guess no that would mean this but
blah blah blah oh but he used that line
i saw him on
cnbc one day and he said the same
[__] thing the exact same [__] way
like a comedian does
in their sets where a comedian if you go
up there and it feels like a comedian
has said this joke a million times
they're bored of it then it's not funny
but a comedian has to sort of like
it's almost like they're realizing or
telling this story for the first time
that's when it really hits and so i saw
him do that and i go
oh there's levels to this [__] like not
only do you have to be able to be good
at it
this is like this is like comedy this is
like storytelling this is like
this is like a play you know a broadway
show that goes on on stage every night
and there's a new person in the crowd
and they have to do it like it's the
this is a tuesday night but no this is
our open this is our best performance
ever this is the first time we've ever
done it
this show matters the most and we repeat
our lines and i thought
oh wow i've never even thought about
that but yeah i guess it makes sense you
could kind of craft these stories
that hit and you could tell them over
and over once you have them
that's in your bank and you can i tell
this story people feel this way about me
and um that's cool so i'm gonna try and
bring this back to the brand thing
but before i do um another way that you
can see this is when you're pitching
stuff
so when you're pitching your company to
people you have to and i mean i did this
well when i when
both when i was selling the company if i
was ever trying to raise money if i'm
ever trying to convince uh
i you know i do when i am on other
podcasts or
and also when i um i'm hiring someone
i've got the same pitch
and i look at the inflection of my all
right i i look at the person's eyebrows
and i look at their body language and
see where i get them to lean in and i
get it i see where i get
a full backwards and you gotta find
these hooks and you constantly got to
throw them out and you got to see what
what what bait works and then you just
rinse and repeat and he was like ooh
that line
right or when i said i want to be like
ted turner [__] they didn't know who ted
turner was okay what else do i got yeah
you wanna exactly exactly um so to bring
it back to judge judy
uh i don't know how i'm gonna yeah bring
her back to jesus let's just move on
uh anyways cool story about michael
buffer and judge judy if you didn't know
they made a bunch of money
uh and you know it pays to have a
personal monopoly
all right that's the podcast
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
my days off
on the road less travel never looking
back